hey guys welcome back to the game spot
stage at e3 2016 i'm your host Mary and
I'm delighted to be joined by my co-host
Peter Brown as well as Hideki Kamiya
creative director at platinum games and
translator JP thank you so much for
being here yeah hi now definitely yeah
the first thing we're going to get into
here would probably be the gameplay demo
that we that was revealed just a couple
days ago where we show we you guys
showed a huge boss fight as well as a
multiplayer for the very first time
pokemon johto boss fight on me stood on
the schedule go ahead we were curious of
what went into the development process
to make the biggest boss fight that has
ever happened yo mama de la cinta games
mantic I borsato ethics code on the scar
maha guru juicy still keep you hooked in
the scale up to state a must so when
touched at all so no maruti dedicated to
pour des anneaux madura von Union
sumitomo a curio Kandarian apostles
karate or the pentax goodness yeah so um
you know the first thing that you do is
you just decide to keep making it bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger until it's cool so we started
there and then we started thinking about
okay now how to make this enormous thing
work and multiplayer and how do you
fight it together with your friends so
it's kind of a really organic process of
taking what we already knew and just
scaling it up to be amazing now you're
playing as the lead character drew and
your dragon Saban sounds like they have
a really interesting relationship could
you talk a little bit about the dynamic
between those two characters Naruto
bagno con que se oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] the
class I mono too long ago I don't even
want Dorian Indian side in the character
they must know it or meager so on Acosta
thought that I got all Priya distinguish
day they are no issue necrotic
articulated Oregon tonight buddy an
acrylic on acoustic reduce anxiety voted
a master natraj karate kata taco loco
con con game saying optimist yes so the
most important part of our kind of
gameplay mechanic is that up until now
in the action games that we've made
you've always been playing kind of a
human-sized character fighting against
enemies and you were the only one on
screen
but now we've kind of picked Drew who is
an everyman he's a guy from our world
he's actually really weak and we've
paired him with a really powerful AI
creature and to bond the dragon and so
the gameplay mechanic doesn't become how
can I be a superhero every single moment
it becomes how do I work together with
this amazing creature to kind of cover
up where I'm weak but also accentuate
where I'm strong a GP last time I talked
to you I know you were writing primarily
a Platinum Games yeah well the case are
you responsible for a sort of Drew's
character and who he is actually i'm not
writing on this one um I'm producing the
game now no yeah yeah I'm Thank You Man
so item we've actually had a really
really cool set of riders on this so um
Kamya has been kind of laying out the
the flesh and bones of the story and
then a lot of the Polish passes and work
has gone in we used a guy for a little
while named rich Bryant who was he's
moved on to a really cool project that I
can't tell you about different companies
I know he's working for us this is all
the places where we worked really deeply
with Microsoft rich was one of the
riders on table 2 table 3 so and after
that you know rich stuff decided to go
take this amazing offer and God bless a
man dudes amazingly talented and Joseph
Staton from Bungie okay um who had
worked obviously on destiny but
basically built the lore for halo
stepped in and also brought one of his
kind of most trusted guys clay Carmouche
who did a lot of the writing for the
taken king yeah search engine producing
and writing is a pretty strong pedigree
yeah we've got really really strong
riders on this but it's still you know
at its core call me a story so we're
staying true to that thanks now going
back to the characters and their
relationship it sounds like now you've
revealed multiplayer but do you guys
still have a really strong single player
option for people are you really kind of
leaning more towards multiplayer at the
station good anymore so we must come on
chica main disco 8080 no no Preston oh
yes a burrito mano de anos Ingrid us so
biryani th o same o same o poco de
grandes que dia para maruti dad smut the
coso conoscere vinovat a national
holiday
oh no a tomato Rico hi ho cherry
hereditary mustn't automation video now
its cricket alstyne not the kinectimals
yeah so um we definitely obviously
premiered co-op and we're really excited
about that but we realize that lots of
different people want to play games in
different ways and some people want to
invest a whole bunch of time and just
kind of playing something by themselves
and tinkering and tweaking and exploring
every corner of the world and sometimes
it's really hard to do in coop so we
support everything from playing by
yourself all the way through the
campaign to play in the entire campaign
with four three other people as a group
of four now AM when you're playing you
are playing with other Drew's correct um
now cuz in in the story you are meant to
be this person who's transported into a
world you are the only drew and this is
your own this is the last dragon how do
you come to terms in the story of having
for drew's and for dragons I know yo to
know the route or to know drag on dating
Landeskog multi con game oh and also
join Chuck socially got a much tougher
game each time that the colonel itt
matsumoto mano con cavaco dirty talk
show taking a character that [ __ ] ain't
gonna just annoy you tokyo technical
octava todo side Nicki Noto Laguna uni
soo soo Yun Connie cano 2nd and a Sunday
Esther naughty no no ma poor again with
the Kurram oh so you put the Anton's
internet a nanny panel session on a
yacht oak wanna to pee Cana Captain de
ma soy Dora dojin sonzai suru koto mo
city may not see on a sec i continue
kong righty this road chant ocean area
of the AI de mas amo con ganas on each
one side when you Nino toluca no bosne
hoto domestic in ecorse hike on his toes
in karnataka yes route to yoga I've
stayed in the skin amo mas oregano
second con the hint when doctor toma de
minas amo emo I go to most little state
and attention do not move to me so we
wanted to make a co-op game from the
very start of this project we're really
excited about making game that you could
play through cooperatively but we also
have this really kind of strong
personality and drew and a really strong
personality to bond and we wanted to
stay true to their story and tell that
story of their bond a lot of times you
could just say ok there's for drew's and
there's fortune bonds because its co-op
game it's video game deal with it and be
really lame so we put a lot of effort in
a lot of thought into how
we could make that concept of a more
story-driven kind of character-driven
action game motif work and co-op and so
it's something that we've tied into the
story and even though we're not talking
a lot about the story of the game right
now we wanted to give people a little
hint and so there is actually a hint in
the gameplay that we showed the other
day at the very end of that video you
see all for drew's kind of go up and get
ready to kind of put the finishing blow
on the boss and all of a sudden collapse
down into each other and that's a hint
as to how kind of the narrative works
for having multiple drews and multiple
bonds but still being courted those
characters that's very interesting cool
I'm super curious about that no me vas a
no-no concarneau boasts an EVO to miss a
semester quedo new boss ended emerge
particular to the NOC there are non
gamers in pants sorry Mon simply post it
on or curiosity chemos yeah and so you
know that's how we pulled off not just
having co-op is just being in this mode
that maybe you go into a boss fight and
then suddenly other people come and help
you out but being able to play that
story driven campaign experience but in
co-op I'm pretty curious about the
structure of the game overall is this
something that is perhaps more linear or
more open world career mod vijnana demon
anoka open wild on Anika dolma conscious
car maybe not wide open work but you
know now open well ma ma yah know even a
couple it's tight and windy soon no we
haven't we have a big debate always
going on in the studio open world
because open world means so many things
so many different people like it can be
sandbox games it can be you know
segmented overworld games I'd be like
super contiguous open world games open
world means so many different things to
people we did right to avoid saying I'll
clarify my question am I going level to
level two level or is this sort of an
adventure that gives me a little bit of
room to deviate and explore mono boot I
know chamaco on Julie volcano quadratic
state masuda danjo meets Katara D'Antoni
high-tech the soda coach otoko chosen
suganuma tech sector ah tita KO tao
stick to each month I've imposed right
1800 hero SE queda thomson que me des
nayika korea start o mo mata an assoc
MODOK tanabata on a she became 10 promo
take
yeah so we want to have a world that's
large that you can explore freely and as
your kind of exploring and fighting Anna
Musial happen upon dungeons and you go
into those dungeons and have like really
tough challenges they're great and then
come out but you will be progressing
along a story but even once you finish
that story if you say you want to go
back and try that dungeon again we
really want to give people the
opportunity to revisit the world and to
revisit the different things that
they've experienced in the context of
that openings open game did you a lot of
traveling via the dragon is he sort of
your vehicle in that respect dragon or
ammonia not even this guy na ito touched
SI ma combat mode mo diamond or not the
kogi through Tommy stationmaster's on my
upper e ru Niang elko taking aqui todo
con are a character na na de Matos de no
he oido de moco not a eurosceptic otomo
the Kirin our desk a go nas vaca story
sot a no torino cotton our say Koko no
no character Naruto to Monty of Steady
Go no code oak is enough come pick okies
noffke matara cause mano pero como te
dejo cima cocci no body shame querida
show see also evening yo gotti coconut
emoti so uh obviously we're totally
wearing we're in the same way that we
definitely want to hop on a dragon and
fly around and move through the world
like that's absolutely something that
you're going to be able to do but it's
not going to be a given we want you to
kind of come to terms with to bond and
you know if you were somebody who just
got suddenly paired with a dragon how do
I relate to this dragon how do I
understand them how do we even get along
before you can hop on his back and say
hey down to the the 7-eleven or
something right so I mean there's some
crazy stuff going on if you're just
transported to another world you have to
like how did I get here what there's
dragons I'm gonna be that's gonna be a
bra so once you kind of come to terms
and become close with to bond and build
that bond that's when things like dragon
riding open up and more attacks and kind
of how you combine with each other opens
up so we really want that kind of
learning progression in the
I'm interested sold me now you you
mentioned that drew was kind of like the
weak character he requires the dragon to
give him strength but he does have some
skills does he not looks like he had
like a scale arm that gave him a few few
helpful things like some armor and a few
powers can you talk about that for a
continuum on a day when I tema de Moura
chikara Morris named King hamaso no in
der Lubbe yacate Mahadeva anika anika
created a no dollar canto or take okey
techno Tahoe zapatos rotatable minute
Hakuna scotoma I know cocky right the
chicken so no a top of it's not any good
scope go today yo your own ass not any
card ya know kogi session continuum oh
honey money yeah so you know we've you
drew is obviously much smaller and
weaker than to bond in combat and using
working together with to bond is how
you're going to kind of overcome things
so there'll be instances will you be
kind of sending him forward and maybe
pulling back a little bit in supporting
them from longer distances or you know
finding a place to hide in setting up
traps if there's lots of different
things that you can do in that respect
but that would get really old really
quick if that was the only thing that
you could do so we gave him that dragon
form mechanic where you have a gauge and
if you press that button you become kind
of one with that dragon and get that
full set of skills and you are now the
superhero and so all of that stress and
fear that you've built up being kind of
small can be just totally expelled out
of your system by just going smacking
the crap out of something because you're
in dragon form well it sounds so
exciting so it sounds like that's pretty
much all we have time for today and I
really appreciate with Hideki Kamiya and
JP talking to us about scalebound and we
do not have a solid released in on this
but I believe we can expect to see it
sometime in 2017 2017 yep all right well
thank you guys so much and thank you
guys for watching you're not going to
want to go anywhere we have a lot more
coming up so stay right here on gamespot